[Música]
la unión europea inició su campaña de
vacunación contra el joven 19 los
primeros ciudadanos en recibir la vacuna
serán personas de edad avanzada y
personal sanitario aunque cada país
establecerá sus prioridades francia
empezó en santaní y dijon mientras que
en bélgica y luxemburgo comienza mañana
lunes alemania hungría y eslovaquia se
adelantaron el sábado 26 de diciembre
millones de estadounidenses perdieron
sus beneficios de desempleo luego del
rechazo del presidente saliente de
donaldson de firmar el nuevo plan de
estímulo aprobado por el congreso tras
la negativa se agotarán los fondos para
la administración que podría entrar en
parálisis parcial el martes a no ser que
se apruebe una medida de financiación
temporal
el senado argentino decide este martes y
aprueba el proyecto de legalización de
la interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
hasta la semana 14 de gestación tras la
aprobación del proyecto hace dos semanas
en la cámara de diputados todas las
miradas están puestas en el senado
históricamente más conservador y que en
2018 voto en contra de un proyecto
similar
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 se redoblan con
gusto saludarlos comenzamos este
informativo en europea porque inició su
campaña de vacunación masiva contra el
hobbit 19 con la vacuna desarrollada por
facer para gente que luego de recibir el
visto bueno de la agencia europea de
medicamentos francia empezó en sant
dennis y dijon españa portugal italia
austria y república checa son algunas de
las naciones que iniciaron el día de hoy
en la que los líderes de la unión
europea llamaron djabe el día de la
vacuna el bloque oficialmente entonces
se embarca en este programa de
vacunación masiva para sus habitantes
más vulnerables y el personal médico la
presidenta de la comisión europea úrsula
von der layen calificó el lanzamiento
del programa de vacunación como un
conmovedor momento de unidad para el uso
450 millones de personas que viven en
los 27 estados miembros por su parte los
ciudadanos expresan su alegría al ser
vacunados
ahora que la paciente ha sido vacunada
podrá ser acompañada de regreso a su
habitación y la vigilaremos de cerca
durante los primeros 15 minutos y luego
mantendremos una vigilancia un poco
menos estricta durante la primera media
hora y luego listo la vacunación habrá
terminado y mientras europa ha asegurado
ya a cientos de millones de dosis para
sus ciudadanos en américa latina' los
comienzos son mucho más modestos veamos
ahora cómo está el panorama en la región
argentina cuenta con 300 mil vacunas
rusas que comenzarán a inocularse el 29
de diciembre méxico dispuso inicialmente
de tan solo tres mil doce dosis de facer
variantes que se aplicaron en el
hospital general de méxico desde el 24
de diciembre y con las 42 mil 900
adicionales que ya llegaron a suelo
azteca seguirá mañana en la capital y
también en coahuila las autoridades
sanitarias de costa rica- empezaron con
9 mil 750 dosis el 24 de diciembre y en
chile 10.000 dosis de facer variante que
también se empezaron a inocular el día
a la vida
así entonces el panorama de vacunación
en américa latina' y millones de
estadounidenses perdieron la ayuda
federal por desempleo debido a la
decisión del presidente de donald trump
de no firmar el proyecto de ley de
ayudas que había sido consensuado por
demócratas y republicanos en el congreso
el presidente electo joe biden advirtió
que la decisión de trump traerá
consecuencias devastadoras
todo estaba en las manos del presidente
donald trump no puso su firma en el
proyecto de ley de estímulo y cerca de
14 millones de estadounidenses perdieron
los beneficios por desempleo por lo
menos por una semana
un acuerdo había sido logrado luego de
meses de negociaciones tortuosos entre
los demócratas y republicanos en el
congreso
pero a inicios de esta semana el
mandatario se rehusó a firmar el
proyecto de ley diciendo que los 600
dólares de ayuda estipulados para los
individuos no eran suficientes
les le pido al congreso que enmiende
este proyecto de ley y aumente los
ridículamente bajos 600 dólares a 2000
el proyecto de ley que ahora planean
enviar a mi escritorio es muy diferente
de lo previsto es realmente una
desgracias palabras que tomaron al
congreso por sorpresa
trump no se opuso al acuerdo el pasado
lunes cuando fue sometido a votación y
de hecho eran los demócratas los que
habían insistido en que los
estadounidenses deberían recibir un
monto más alto de verona créanlo o no
los demócratas están de acuerdo con el
presidente 600 dólares no son
suficientes para los individuos que la
han pasado mal durante los últimos siete
meses y no son suficientes para darle un
impulso a las necesidades de nuestra
economía
con su decisión tramposo millones de
dólares de ayuda económica en el limbo
incluyendo 286 mil millones para las
familias y los desempleados 284 mil
millones para los pequeños negocios y 70
mil millones para las vacunas y pruebas
de covite
también dentro del acuerdo estaba una
pausa en las órdenes de desalojos sin
ella millones de personas perderán sus
viviendas el proyecto de ley también
contempla 14 billones de dólares en
funcionamiento del gobierno lo que
significa que si no hay firma para
entonces la administración tendrá que
cerrar parcialmente a la medianoche del
lunes las autoridades estadounidenses
creen que la explosión del viernes en el
centro de la ciudad de nación cnc pudo
ser un acto suicida elwood o el buró
federal de investigación fbi y allanó
tras una orden judicial una vivienda en
el barrio de ancho en el sureste de la
ciudad para determinar si los aparentes
restos humanos que se hallaron en la
zona de la explosión pertenecían a la
persona que residía en esa casa las
autoridades han identificado a un
posible sospechoso del ataque un hombre
blanco de 63 años
en argentina el senado decide este
martes y aprueba el proyecto de
legalización de la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo la iniciativa ya
fue aprobada en primera instancia por
los diputados hace dos semanas y conocen
adores divididos entre verdes
partidarios de realizarlo y los celestes
los contrarios y la votación emparejada
a la vicepresidenta cristina fernández
será quien preside el senado será quien
decide se va a ser a espinoza nos cuenta
más
a puertas de convertirse en ley el
aborto libre en argentina está en manos
del senado el proyecto de ley que
plantea que se permita interrumpir el
embarazo hasta la semana 14 ya fue
aprobado por la cámara de diputados- y
este martes cerca de 70 senadores
deciden sobre el proyecto de ley que
lleva a la firma del presidente alberto
fernández los de si o verdes aseguran
que la penalización hace que miles de
mujeres mueran al llevar a cabo abortos
clandestinos tenemos el derecho a poder
decidir sobre nuestros proyectos de vida
sobre si queremos o no queremos tener
hijos y de querer tenerlos cuántos
queremos tener y si decidimos
interrumpir el embarazo que lo podamos
hacer de manera autónoma y libre sobre
nuestros cuerpos y vidas los del no
los celestes se fundamentan en que el
feto ya es una vida que descartemos a
nuestros hijos porque si por meros
deseos pudiendo nos hacernos cargo
pudiendo afrontar digamos y llevar
adelante ese embarazo es la necesidad de
legislar por deseos por deseos yo te
deseo y sos una persona yo no te deseo y
por arte de magia dejaste de ser una
persona y te puedo desechar
y a mí esto me parece gravísimo en el
año 2018 el proyecto de ley de la
intervención del embarazo se quedó
estancado en el senado de llegar a un
empate la encargada de decidir es la
actual vicepresidenta cristina fernández
de kirchner quien está a favor del
proyecto con presiones de la iglesia y
otros colectivos sociales el congreso
será una vez más sede de manifestaciones
se estima que en la nación suramericana
se realizan más de 300.000 abortos
clandestinos al año decenas de mujeres
mueren durante el procedimiento que en
argentina sólo es legal cuando la vida
salud física y mental de la madre está
en peligro o cuando el embarazo es
producto de una violación
los centroafricanos ya comenzaron a
votar para elegir un nuevo presidente y
a sus 140 diputados pero una parte del
país no podrá ejercer su derecho en una
nación hundida en la guerra civil y la
pobreza
el presidente saliente fausta narró
santus deja es el gran favorito pero los
grupos rebeldes que controlan dos
tercios del territorio quieren impedir
su reelección bajo amenaza las tropas
internacionales vigilan la capital banco
y miles de israelíes se protestaron en
contra del primer ministro benjamin
netanyahu en jerusalén por su presunta
corrupción y el manejo del gobierno de
la crisis de kobe 19 hoy el estado judío
entrará en su tercer confinamiento en lo
que va de la pandemia el país celebrará
elecciones anticipadas en marzo después
de que el parlamento no cumpliera el
martes 22 de diciembre el plazo para
aprobar un presupuesto con una población
de 9 millones de habitantes israel
confirmó 343 mil 665 casos positivos
registrados y 2 mil 901 muertes
hasta aquí el informativo continúe con
nosotros feliz día
[Música]
versalles el lugar